[Music]
I just thing I've done for someone yeah
oh come on now that's a hard one yeah
so I went to a party one time in college
and I found my friend who is a girl
passed out on the ground was gonna might
be a little depressing but I I work in a
hospital and there was a really old man
used on hospice his family didn't make
it in time so I held his hand as he
passed away we think that she got like
some GHB or something so I carried her
like two miles back to her dorm I don't
know I guess I helped a bird I save the
birds or I don't know there was an old
man and he was like struggling down the
street and they just asked me to open
toys shoe so I did that and then I
helped him walk to the butchers and then
just helped him walk took it as a gay
lift a friend of his was picking him up
my grandfather's best friend's wife was
dying them all fenced and the people
that she picked to look after were very
good at looking after and so I promised
that I would and I did that or better
part of I guess five years out of the
last seven or so every day everything I
had it worked out really good night I
took funny from it
and I learned a lot of my life and all
sorts of things someone asked me for
gags last week and I give them like
almost Empire hey I do addict
oh my gosh when I was at work somebody
was blind and I was helping them shot
for significant other Sarah my country I
could
ah
help somebody back help someone back on
the road
fix a tire so I had a friend in college
who had been through like a lot of stuff
in his life just seemingly one of those
people that every shitty thing happened
to and then he also kind of increased it
with like addiction to drug and alcohol
and them the moment sticks out to me
that we were hanging out with him and
his roommate and it's like they had this
great relationship where they just kind
of banter with each other and give each
other [ __ ] and he was talking about how
he had scars on his arms from like you
know cutting and stuff and how whenever
he goes to like a medical service place
or like goes to get blood drawn they
always really judge him for it
he was like yeah the nurses like judge
me and this is like my first time
meeting him and I was just like oh god
I'm so sorry that's really shitty and I
don't know it's hard to explain but I
could tell that no one had ever had that
response before
so he just looked at me and he was like
oh thanks for saying that
and yes so I guess that's not like a
traditional nice gesture but I could
tell it meant a lot to him yeah so
that's what came to mind I think the
kindest thing I've ever done is just to
love somebody I buy coffee for people at
the circle-k
you're somebody in line that just buying
coffee or small thing don't go pay for
them and just leave before they can say
anything actually carried her bike five
flights up to our apartment and it's not
like a small bike it's like a mountain
bike so I did it for her cuz I'll
there's broken I bought a car for a
resident in domestic crisis shelter but
I was on the board of directors before
hmm I've never thought about that
question so you really make me take care
I want to make sure I give a good answer
let's get a good take my time here
it would probably be brief pray for
someone that they got the thing that I
wanted I think that was the kind of
thing I ever did for the chance I'm
afraid for them to get it I was trying
to give it up you know from my heart
beating laying on the money
let them live in my house they got
kicked out of a house written free eggs
is especially London Bay Area sure I was
in that why just be a support for him
honestly the kindest thing I've done for
someone what time I bought a guy I'm a
pharmacist and he came in his home less
than a year this job interview coming up
so I bought him all kinds of shower
stuff to get ready for his interview I
would say I try to do something kind for
at least one person every single day if
it's buying someone true that can't
afford it or helping out friends on a
daily basis that neither lending hand
it's whatever I could do to help out
give a nice compliment healthy my sister
with Charlie will come to scoff
counselor hmm I hope some people get a
job and change their career telephone I
bought my friend around to drink that's
the most recent nicest thing I did I
guess a recent example one I worked as
an EMT for a long time and I guess I
went out of the world every now that off
the a medical emergency that happens in
real life and a lot of people just kind
of walk by you know aren't sure what to
do and
I guess I always think it's kind of my
responsibility to do something if I have
the capability we don't know if this is
a huge order for the Special Olympics
I bought somebody a coat the other day
who is asking just for money
actually we have shown up today and we
give them some dollars but you also
helped us up as well so you get the
airport pick up our rental car I don't
think I know of the money um I bought
somebody a miller one huh yeah so I mean
it's interesting that you would do this
project because that's a very good
question to ask make people think about
you're going to say my say you're right
okay so uragan that you're going to say
the kind of things she's done for you
and you'll say the kind of thing she's
done for you
I'll go first okay she is my sister okay
refer name is Juliana and I'm Teresa um
and you have done many kind things from
your eyeliner but the most recent one is
she came out actually for our family our
grandmother is kind of struggling I
passed she passed away recently and she
came out to be of support to our mother
the family and cheese I have a hard job
in Sochi has been cleaning my blazer
yeah no person cleaning my place and
like doing all of my laundry and just
cooking meals everyday spending Simon
keeping their attention
oh I'm not a kind person so she stroked
yeah the older so I just got out of beat
down well I think the kind of thing he's
ever done is listening to me without
judgment so if ever have an issue I know
that I can come to her and I can be the
wackiest thing or the hardest thing so
no thank you
[Music]
you